Interesting shape Pockin It
seems that it's hard to move the launch I'm so full of
energy I wonder why I'm going to fit in the future I wonder why I'm in this shape
I feel love
How do you make the lid through animals?
Yeah
[Music]
The name of the bus has fallen to one.
I'm an artist.
When I make works, I mainly make animals using newspaper.  The
ones I've made so far are the first to have a wife.
After that, the leader voice actor Governor's issue
jack rabbit Sea turtles and about 60 points.
First of all, I went small at home, but I think that I have a factory here and
it is now an atelier, but
this was used at the paper string factory.
I think that the history of the good performance of the paper strings that I used
to do is linked to the fact that I make works using the current paper. The
way to make works is to twist the newspaper first and then stack it in layers.  I'm going to make a shape I
want to make it as if I'm alive.
Animal 1 If it's a big one,
it will take about 3 to 1 month to make it together.
When I got the chance to go to the newspaper and saw the sign at that time, I started making
animals when I said that there was a wife who had been hurt by being robbed of her horns by a poacher
.
You can die by looking through the animals, and you can
feel that you are alive, or that you can
feel that it is natural.
I want to continue to the point where I can continue
[Music]